WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY, I THINK IT'S A
DISGRACE.
THE MEMO WAS SENT TO
CONGRESS.
IT WAS DECLASSIFIED.
CONGRESS WILL DO WHATEVER
THEY'RE GOING TO DO.
BUT I THINK IT'S A DISGRACE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT
EARLIER TODAY REACTING TO
THE STUNNING FISA MEMO WHICH
WAS, IN FACT, DECLASSIFIED.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION
NORTH CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN
MARK MEADOW, OHIO
CONGRESSMAN FREEDOM CAUCUS
MEMBER JIM JORDAN.
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, LET'S
START WITH YOU.
I WAS WONDERING AT TIMES IF
PEOPLE WERE OVERSELLING
THIS.
AND MANY IN WAYS I THINK YOU
UNDERSOLD IT IN THIS
ABUSE OF POWER, CORRUPTION,
SCANDAL WE HAVE EVER HAD
WHERE HAVE YOU ONE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE USING
PHONY RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA,
HIGHEST RANKING PEOPLE IN
THE DOJ, IN THE FBI USING
THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE TO TRY AND SPY
ON AND SUCCESSFULLY SPY ON
AND HOPEFULLY DERAIL AN
OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATE
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN THIS
BEFORE, CONGRESSMAN.
>> WELL, WE HAVEN'T, SEAN.
AND YOU HAVE BEEN COVERING
THIS FOR MANY, MANY MONTHS.
IN FACT, WHEN EVERYBODY WAS
CREDIT SIZING YOU, ABOUT
WHAT YOU BELIEVED TO BE
GOING ON, TODAY WE NOW KNOW
THAT, INDEED, IT WAS GOING
ON.
SEAN, I CAN TELL YOU
PROBABLY THE THING THAT
CONCERNS ME THE MOST IS THAT
THIS IS THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
WE ARE ALREADY LOOKING AND
REVIEWING OTHER DOCUMENTS
AND OTHER SOURCES OF
COLLUSION.
COLLUSION BETWEEN THIS
PRESIDENT AND THE RUSSIANS.
BUT NOW WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
COLLUSION ACTUALLY DID TAKE
PLACE.
BUT IT WAS FROM THE HILLARY
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND REALLY
TRY TO AFFECT THE ELECTION
THROUGH THIS DOSSIER THAT
THEY PAID FOR AND WAS USED
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN JORDAN,
I WATCHED NEW COMMITTEES AND
THERE WERE TIMES FINALLY
SOMEBODY IS SAYING IT.
I FELT LIKE I WAS HANGING
OUT HERE ON A THREAD BY
MYSELF SOME NIGHTS WITH SOME
OF MY GOOD PARTNERS AND
FRIENDS ON THE SHOW.
BUT IT IS WORSE THAN WE
THOUGHT.
AND I'M TOLD THAT WE NIGHT
PROSECUTE V. A GRASSLEY MEMO
NEXT WEEK THAT TAKES IT YET
TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
>> REMEMBER WHAT WE LEARNED
TODAY, SEAN, NOT ONCE, NOT
TWICE, NOT THREE TIMES BUT
FOUR TIMES THE TOP PEOPLE AT
THE FBI TOOK THIS SALACIOUS
AND UNVERIFIED DOCUMENT.
THIS DOSSIER TO THE SECRET
COURT TO GET A SECRET
WARRANT TO SPY ON A FELLOW
THAT THE DEMOCRAT NATIONAL
COMMITTEE AND THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN PAID FOR IT FOUR
OPPORTUNITIES TO TELL THE
TRUTH TO THE COURT AND THEY
DIDN'T DO IT TO SPY ON A
FELLOW CITIZEN.
AND THEY DID THAT IN THE
CONTEXT OF A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
AS MARK JUST SAID, THIS
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN IN THIS
GREAT COUNTRY.
>> Sean: IT NEVER SHOULD.
SO CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN?
I WOULD ARGUE WITHOUT ALL OF
THIS, WHAT WE ARE DESCRIBING
AND TALKING ABOUT TONIGHT,
THERE IS NO SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER.
AND I'M SAYING HE NEEDS TO
GO YESTERDAY.
WE KNOW TONIGHT.
>> WELL, WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
MUCH OF THE INFORMATION THAT
ACTUALLY CALLED FOR A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR WAS
TAINTED.
AND WHEN WE SEE THAT, YOU
INVESTIGATION.
AND IT'S VERY TROUBLING.
I BELIEVE THAT SPECIAL
COUNSEL MURIEL WILL COME
BACK
MUCK
MUELLER WILL SHOWTHIS PRESIDENTD
MUELLER WILL SHOWTHIS PRESIDENT'
MUELLER WILL SHOWTHIS PRESIDENTT
COLLUDE WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THE PROBLEM IS THERE WAS A
WHOLE LOT, JIM WAS JUST
TALKING ABOUT IT, FOUR TIMES
THEY WENT TO A FISA COURT TO
SPY ON AMERICAN CITIZENS.
BUT THREE OF THOSE TIMES
HILLARY'S IN THE BEGINNING.
>> THEY DID.
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
>> Sean: THAT OMISSION IS A
LIE.
NEXT?
WHAT'S THE NEXT STEP IN
TERMS OF IF WE WANT TO RIGHT
THIS TREMENDOUS INJUSTICE
AND CONSTITUTIONAL
VIOLATION?
>> THE THING MARK AND I AND
SEVERAL OTHER MEMBERS CALLED
FOR SIX MONTHS AGO, A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WE KNOW MUELLER CAN'T EXPAND
HIS PROBE HE IS INHERENTLY
COMPROMISED ON THIS.
WE KNOW JEFF SESSIONS HAS
RECUSED HIMSELF.
I'M NOT A FAN OF SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
I WOULD ADD ONE THING, MAKE
SURE THEY ARE NOT FROM THE
SWAMP.
MAKE SURE IT'S SOME RETIRED
FEDERAL JUDGE FROM IOWA OR
OKLAHOMA OR SOMEWHERE.
PICK SOMEONE TO COME IN AND
LOOK AT THIS ENTIRE
AGENCIES IN OUR GOVERNMENT.